[Music]
and case closed news please close please
submitted by nermal nermal I'd said that
good and you are I'm normal normal
normal
Garfield telephones kept washing ashore
in France but now the mystery has been
solved that's funny like Garfield oh
bugger
the cartoon for 30 years
pieces of Garfield phone kept washing
ashore on the beaches of Northwestern
wait there's a mystery isn't there like
the [ __ ] shipping boat like capsized
and all of the inventory fell in the
ocean and now it's getting washed up
Oh did the real history is Somalian
pirates are a big fans of Garfield so
they've been keeping all the phones on
board but then they got attacked so
they'd just been dropping all these
phones on but still the capsizing Siri I
said yeah that's not a shipment cargo
it's by Somali oh okay yeah so this is
what they look like oh my god
I'm gonna buy one right now oh yeah damn
I miss landline phone no you don't want
the [ __ ] wrong with you backward
there's a little link you can like a
plug you plug into your phone but it has
like the hook of all yeah so you might
think that an urban outfitters on
charging your phone now okay if you
don't put my new phone use the new
phones you can just do it right like
this you can [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] good
but now your neck hurts like it's too
low now we have like [ __ ] Bluetooth
cable because you missed commercials oh
really you want to see commercials best
comedy in the world
oh [ __ ] the oh I'm commercials over in
Oregon Oh have you ever had trouble
opening a banana
it's a black-and-white remember watching
so much TV when I was a teenager that I
actually memorized all the commercials
like the entire script like I would
literally say it as it was playing cuz
they would play it so frequently over
and over and over again and that's how
much TV I watched sorry I would actually
say the entire conversion I can remember
what it felt like sitting there and
watching TV for hours and it does feel
like your brain is melting yeah feels
like your brain is [ __ ] even my
eyeballs felt like yours melting off you
don't feel that way with like Netflix
are like YouTube videos for me I only
watched the same things I always watch
but I'm not you're watching it I just
have this background like you're on your
phone and stuff well I'm on my phone I'm
like working or some [ __ ] I have it yeah
[ __ ] right yeah you want family guy
all the time exactly as background noise
no on the couch staring at it like this
whipped up with his head on a pillow and
his feet up ha what was I doing before
watching the other episode you wanted
making a [ __ ] film [ __ ] in your face
Wow defensive because yeah that's
pocketville those are the days okay
anyway so yeah so four years
people and like environmental people
just kept trying to figure out what the
hell is happening here where is this
shipping container or both that has
capsized we need to find this because
this is obviously not good for the
environment like this pollution plastic
pollution and and so I thought they were
worried about the phones I was more was
more worried about the phones in the
fish coming from and why do they keep
coming you know yeah so in 2018 alone at
least 200 pieces of garbage had been
found on the beaches [ __ ] a lot yep
so cats don't deserve these phones we do
so because of all of this media and like
recently there's just been more public
publicity for this weird phenomenon
and this one day this man remembered
back when he was 19 or 20 years old in
the mid eighties he and his brother
started noticing that there were all
these Garfield phones washing ashore and
so they were like oh I wonder if we
could find like where these things are
coming from and so they went into they
went exploring and they found this cave
and inside that cave there was this huge
shipping container that had all these
phones but don't ask me why they didn't
tell anyone cuz I don't even know but
all these years they kept that to
himself he kept that and so he ended up
going to this environmentalist
lady that was cleaning out the beach and
said hey you looking for the Garfield
phones and then 30 years later
hey yeah and he was like come with me I
can show you oh my baby went come with
me I can show you yeah it's a wall
French and then um so they went towards
that cave but now this cave is like it
was sort of submerged so it was too
dangerous to go in so they had to wait
until the tide went down and finally
they went in and they found this
shipping container I was all like
deteriorated and there was Garfield
pieces all over the place but this
environment environmentalist Lee was
saying like well I mean cool we found it
but there's still plastic all over the
place we know there's now there's like
this metal up here that's like not very
safe for the environment either so
they're gonna try to remove it and stuff
but at least now the whole mystery has
been solved they found the origin of all
these Garfield bones and that's it it's
not salt cuz why the [ __ ] is it in there
in the first place now how do I get in
the cave let me go back to the other
picture I forgot how cute Garfield was
how cute that [ __ ]
separated yeah yeah those things are
Shore and I'm like just chill that I
don't know looks like it yeah like hind
legs I still watched that cartoon every
morning he was really grumpy huh yeah I
didn't
because of him Kukui beat-up dogs I like
you
that's his owner no it was just a
different cartoon but it was a cat okay
okay
Heathcliff what did you look at the
orange cat - huh I don't remember
he's like grayish I'm like that's good
yeah he was like a tabby cat like a
great tabby oh my god well with you
about uh he was like a junkyard like
shriek cat uh and he just was like rough
around the edges and like he was like a
little thug yeah with this guy like
Garver was just a dick it was a bad day
the dog stupid for me I like them cuz
I'm like oh he's so innocent he just
gets taken advantage of like I feel all
tiny not Snoopy Garfield Calvin and
Hobbes those in my 3,000 but then Winnie
the Pooh was up there above everybody
else that pantless pervert really he's a
pervert wait he was well you just have
any parents who walk around this big out
I thought it was a girl woody yeah I
thought Christopher Robin I guess was
originally based off of a girl of a
young girl but Christopher Robin was a
boy in the in the book and then in the
stuff I guess from what I've read I
don't know why but I like saw it on
Twitter or something that we need the
pool was a girl and everybody was like
oh my childhood is a lie
no for me was a Tweety Bird she's a girl
Tweety was a boy right wait don't
the ball headed by hit it hard I try to
pull eat ass is that the yellow one
right though the ball one yeah she's
yeah yeah I know what you're talking
about yeah or she's bossy yeah color she
I call it no I thought it was a boy the
whole time yeah I think the voice is
very manly is it
I don't know I was very like what did he
say in Spanish I don't remember what I
just say I'm up you're lean his name is
Calibri
yeah so like a lot of people a lot of
Mexican guys that's her nickname
fielding after I leave it's after that
oh he's really sorry to hate that
[ __ ] name then just calling that [ __ ]
my name is lucky Hector [ __ ] man
it's ingrained in the Mexican culture
that like whatever your insecurity is
like they might not like that
gimme a [ __ ] skinny I might as play
at that which is like dark-skinned it
you know dark-skinned I know but if you
see my sisters and stuff I mean you see
my mom they have pink skin that sounds
[ __ ] tight that when you was little
and they we called him Gordo forever you
know he lost all the weight it's just
whatever you're sitting security or
whatever sticks out about you that's
your nickname and it's endearing
yes about credit in Spanish well they
give tea when you're little oh yeah
mistake with the common mistake yeah
Amos Lee there's a there's a kid I know
his whole family just calls him boy just
because he's like the 12th kid and they
just [ __ ] don't care anymore
he's even named them huh I don't know
what his real name is we actually had a
dog in our family that they didn't want
anyone so they call him boy this same
shits his name is boy your boy I think
one of the most [ __ ] up nicknames like
in Mexican like culture is save us which
like or say Warsaw do you know how do
you say so there were signs like a lot
like like a lot of Sally light or right
like a lot of what is that you like no
no but what is the thing that you cook
with the maanteeeca go see someone
thicker lard lard lard okay so basically
they're calling somebody like a lar head
like so also like because if you're big
like tub like oil so also you know what
I mean and that's cool but I always
think several with like like fatty but
then also sadly lady like I've never
heard of that we do never heard that
what is she so skinny that's why she
would never hear she doesn't understand
my dad would call my sister because
she's fat you would call her Cabaye you
mean like how are you like a horse
all the time like they call you that
you're like okay nobody used to [ __ ]
hate it's like no by cesarean well
you're really cute though cuz it's come
on you alright but then you would make
it like I keep smiling yeah something
like that okay my sister little ball boy
ate that Lolita yeah it's cute
my dad's nickname for me was to birthday
Chipotle cute like a it's like a bump in
your head yeah cuz you're probably gonna
bump in his head and then my dad calls
my mom go home oh the biggest turtle
yeah like a big slow [ __ ] pendejo
like the master of my mom would be like
don't [ __ ] call me that
she gets the jobs too late huh I don't
know I invent one he'd be having a doubt
explain it to me before oh really like
she doesn't she gets the jokes too late
she would clown on her and then she
doesn't get it and then who taught the
explain it and this is at all what we
call a kook we which is like devil or
the boogeyman yeah dude we and then I
have another one that looks agents of
course naturally you call them and Chino
yeah well you know in the chat ball the
short guy that's why today no pero el
chapo yeah
chopped almond short chapo yeah I like
tough battle so I chopped was just short
for that do it I had a friend that his
nickname was before for the photo
you did he owned it so much like he
named his kid his sons all fit which is
deaf all backwards
oh my that's kind of everything sounds
good in Spanish though though you know I
mean like what dope we have a lot of
love and like especially if you make it
little like if you're like oh like
people eat that you know what I mean you
make it cute and little so you're like
hope I have like a fruity little kid
what's up Marty kaan cito particle
cheeto Monica Seto yeah yes they eat or
you thought to the end and it makes you
very endearing
[Music]